foreign
for the Press preview then it's our
first look at what is on tomorrow's
front pages and having a look at the
headlines with us tonight contributing
editor at Navara media moyolovium clay
now I'm the chief executive at the total
politics group Mark Wallace they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight a very good evening to both of
you we'll chat in a moment after we've
had a look at those front pages
beginning with the I which leads on the
Privileges committee reports into Boris
Johnson saying he lied and lied and lied
meanwhile the Metro asks if his alleged
lies to parliament are career ending
the Ft says he's being condemned in a
damning report
while the guardian focuses on that
90-day suspension the committee
recommended for Boris Johnson had he
still been a member of parliament here's
the daily mail it says Tory MPS and
Grassroots activists have been left
Furious by the party gate report
the telegraph also focuses on the
response of Boris Johnson's allies
response to the report saying they will
oust the MPS who vote for his censure
The Daily Express describes the
committee's findings as the most
spiteful stitch up in the history of
politics
and no holes barred from The Daily Star
which depicts Boris Johnson as Pinocchio
and don't forget you can scan that QR
code that you see on screen during the
program and you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers that while
you watch us discussing them and tonight
we're joined by Mike Logan McLean and
Mark Wallace great to see you both on
this uh rather warm and humid evening
and uh it's interesting looking at the
front pages because they are very split
we've got the mail saying it's
vindictive while the I says he lied and
lied and lied Mark we knew this report
would be damning but it was scathing
wasn't it
absolutely very much so I've got to say
Jonathan somehow every time we review
the papers together something massive
seems to happen you know oh to have a
quiet night of news
um yes the report was absolutely
scathing it didn't pull any punches and
a lot of the evidence that went with it
including from uh unnamed special
advisors other people around Downing
Street added yet more quite shocking
detail but frankly I don't think
tomorrow's newspapers are going to have
quite enough space to go through and
pick over all the details from it we'll
see several more days of Fallout from
the report alone clearly the MPS on that
committee I think were not um we're not
calmed in their response by the way
Boris Johnson had conducted himself with
regard to the inquiry and we're hearing
a lot of you know bile and Fury from
from the former prime minister and from
his um most enthusiastic and devoted
supporters But ultimately it comes down
when you look at a report like this in
terms of the original behavior and then
the lies to try and excuse and divert
and direct from it the only hasn't
himself to blame if you if Boris Johnson
had been whiter than white as he ought
to and you know as part of the price of
getting to run the country
um by following everything that he is he
and his own government had set out and
then if stuff had gone wrong if he put
his hands up to it he wouldn't be in
this position but he isn't ultimately a
spiteful angry tone to a report as he as
his allies are alleging doesn't change
the the material that it found yeah but
Mark he says uh it was up rather
than conspiracy doesn't he and he says
that this is all all a vendetta
well he says that it's a vendetta
there's a slight degree of um he would
say that wouldn't he to quote someone
else involved in a different Scandal
some decades ago
um but the fact is that this report
doesn't say mistakes were made you know
we've all heard a thousand and one
reports from different arms of the
British State over the years says
mistakes were made lessons will be
learned it says that there were lies and
that is a fundamentally different thing
that's about uh knowing untruth not
mistakes of a mission or just
overlooking things the fact is that
everyone watching this show tonight will
remember what those rules were like we
can remember their force and then you
know the the the vital importance of
them we can remember when they got
absurd and things like the the the the
the snacks and debate over the Scotch
egg counted as a substantial meal in a
pub and all that kind of stuff the fact
is the people around the country went
through an awful lot
um in that Dreadful period and
understandably they're Furious and they
find out people who are setting the
rules making rules were breaking rules
yeah uh Moya we're looking ahead to
Monday there's going to be a vote uh in
the house the front page of the Metro
which uh seems to be on a run of uh of
good headlines at the moment is proper
Whopper a career stopper
um what's your verdict on on this whole
Affair and do you think that Boris
Johnson's political career is over now
but I think good headlines are in the
eye of the beholder definitely Rhymes
um I don't know boris's career is over
you'd think that something like this
would be so big so damning that no one
can ever come back from it but if you
look at the history of British
government plenty of people have
recovered their careers in some manner
or other whether that is within
Parliament or without you look at the
chilco inquiry after that you saw that
Tony Blair Master Campbell would
probably never be on Frontline politics
again in the same manner but they still
have careers Boris Johnson made over one
million pounds last year in speaking
fees alone he might not be back in the
Commons as an MP but that doesn't mean
that he won't continue to profit from
his long 18 years within Parliament or
whether he will still be involved in
politics in some manner as a Statesman
who gives his opinions I think that we
have a very short-term memory when it
comes to disgraced politicians in this
country and Moya what about the uh the
verdict of the committee a 90-day
suspension
um if he'd still be an MP of course um
but but he resigned do you think that is
is fair some are arguing it's perhaps
overreaching
well that 90-day suspension was actually
imposed because of Boris Johnson's
premature response to the committee's
confidential letter that they sent him
last week saying look this is what we've
decided it was going to be a 20-day
suspension but because Boris Johnson
decided to jump the gun resign not take
the suspension in case it triggered a
by-election you'd have to leave in what
he saw as I guess a losing to the
committee's rulings instead he decided
to jump before he was pushed and because
of that and because of what he said in
that letter that he released when he
said he was resigning with an immediate
effect they increased the suspension to
90 days it's rather you know bolting
um The Barn Door after the horse has
already gone but there's clear they gave
they gave very clear articulate reasons
for why they'd increase the suspension
because of this campaign that they
called of abuse that they said Boris
Johnson had been complicit in and there
also might be a follow-up report that is
coming this was threatened by the
Privileges committee about that abuse
and the camp painting on the behalf of
John Boris Johnson's allies that sought
to undermine The credibility of the
Privileges committees and those that sat
upon it so that the verdicts when it was
delivered on Boris Johnson would not be
taken as seriously and as we've seen
would be surrounded by this miasma of
conspiracy
okay well let's have a look at the front
page of the daily mail or we can imagine
uh their take the headline Tory Revolt
over vindictive bid to banish Boris
um where does all this leave Mark uh the
Grassroots conservatives many of whom
are still big fans of of Boris Johnson
and and indeed the public
well I think it's possible to kind of
over egg the idea of a um you know there
may well be a tour of Revolt as the male
says I'm skeptical that there'll be a
Civil War and some commentators have
been saying I think if you see in
parliamentary terms I think Boris
Johnson hasn't managed to hold together
his support base on the green ventures
in the House of Commons
um anywhere near as strongly as he might
have liked in the Grassroots he has a uh
from the evidence I've seen a minority
but sizable minority of people who are
still very enthusiastic about it and who
are very annoyed about this I've got to
say touching on what Molly just said
this format of a committee investigating
a committee potentially uh Committee of
other MPS deciding whether you trigger
whether a punishment should pass a
boundary that potentially triggers a
by-election I think is a far is a less
than ideal one I think it does leave the
road open for there to be dispute and
allegations of personal bias and so on
back in the Coalition years and the
Tories were elected in 2010 promising
there will be what's called a recall
power the idea that voters would get to
choose if enough voters in the
constituency in a short enough time
signed a petition or similar they'll be
able to trigger a by-election that was
watered down with the with the live Dems
and the Coalition agreement and the
conservatives agreed to water it down
and Zach Goldsmith actually Boris
Johnson Ally was the person proposing
full fact recall that we put this in the
hand of photos it was watered down that
produced this committee fudge and I
think we can see that it's a less than
ideal route because it crosses over
whether people are being partisan or
whether political or personal dislikes
coming into it that leaves it open in
this kind of arguments I'm also quite
uncomfortable with the idea the
committee should start disciplining
people who criticize the committee
um you know I think if you're going to
have a system like this you do need to
stop someone you can't have a kind of uh
approach in which you start saying you
should be punished for criticizing the
way in which the committee goes about
things
you might like its conclusions or not
but parliamentarians should be free to
decide that and voters should decide
who's this empowerment yeah interesting
point um and Moya before we move on to
to our next story
um our political editor better be said
tonight that the vote on Monday will be
a litmus test really for for Boris
Johnson and his standing now would you
agree with that
I mean obviously I also I just want to
come back on the point that Mark made
well I totally agree that there's always
to be more power put within the
Grassroots rather than just amps we
should have a full functioning democracy
what's interesting about this committee
and the you know allegations that they
say were abusive towards them is that
throughout this process Boris Johnson
his allies have been claiming that this
is a kangaroo court they said this is a
Witch Hunt they've been using all this
very inflammatory language four of the
seven MPS on that committee are breast
tears it is a Tory Laden committee and
it was one that was put together when
Boris Johnson was still prime minister
he had the opportunity to whip the MPS
to make sure that Harriet Harman who has
been the focus of a lot of these attacks
and accusations of bias was not the head
of that committee that didn't happen at
the time
it's there's criticism and there's what
the allies of Boris Johnson and Boris
Johnson have been doing which is why it
has led to this uh verdict that there's
been a campaign to undermine The
credibility of this committee and I
would say that that has been accurate
what happens now and whether there
should be further action taken you know
it seems a bit ridiculous if we get to
the report on a report on a report about
who did what but there's no denying that
has there has been a concert concerted
effort to make the committee look like
it was biased in a way that it simply
wasn't
okay listen we're going to move on
because we're heading towards the break
and I want to just uh touch on the front
of the guardian and this awful story
today it's on the on the right of the
the guardian about this
um sinking of a migrant vessel Mark
feared that 500 uh are uh uh hopes fade
for 500 still feared uh Missing I mean
this is a real tragedy
absolutely a horrendous um news about
which we're still learning uh yet more
um as you say that that Guardian report
covers a gentleman who's flown to Greece
in search of his wife who he believes
was on this ship and he is left with no
news no information no cloudy on what
appears to be one of the worst Maritime
disasters of of recent years and again
it seems
um people being put in deadly power and
dying at the hands of completely
ruthless
um people smuggling gangs
yeah my women and children as well
believed to be on board
yeah those reports early reports are
saying that at least a hundred children
were in the hole and what this will come
down to is we've seen time and time
again is also not just looking at the
people smuggling gangs but looking at
the authorities that were involved or
not involved in the rescue process has
already been conflicting reports about
authorities not coming to help when they
were asked and the authorities in Greece
are saying no that people refused help
what we've seen in the past with the the
disaster that happened in the channel is
there is a long-term back and forth
before any families or victims or
survivors get answers about what really
happened and that's going to be an even
more torturous process for those who are
left yeah just uh desperate isn't it
okay both thank you for the moment we'll
speak again uh shortly coming up after
the break the metro and other papers
have the latest from Nottingham a huge
vigil was held this evening following
the attacks which left three people
there discussing that and more
[Music]
hello welcome back Moya and Mark are
still with us part two of The Press
preview
um Moya let's talk about events in
Nottingham because yet again today close
family members of those who died
um gave remarkable speeches their
bravery uh in standing up and addressing
the crowds was incredible and actually
also really unusual isn't it to see
relatives going through this sort of
trauma prepared to do something like
this
I would say in more recent years I've
remembered there have been a number of
families who've made a point of standing
up and saying like um Grace O'Malley
Kumar's mother did please don't have any
Hate in Your Hearts which was a really
key emotive line from this I remember
when the London Bridge attacks occurred
then we saw the family of the young man
that was killed Jack they stood up and
said something very very similar and put
out public statements and I think it is
a reflection of the current political
climate we live in and perhaps the speed
at which information is circulated
across social media you get all these
tidbits about the person who is alleged
to have attacked these young people and
Ian Coates who was also killed in
Nottingham and you get a lot of
speculation immediately
none of this is helpful for families who
are grieving but also the pursuit of
justice for their lost ones and we have
seen it more frequently I was saying in
recent years that families have come out
and said please don't jump to
conclusions please don't say this please
don't say that please don't have hate
that's not what our lost loved ones
believed in and they made some
absolutely devastating speeches the you
know Barnaby Weber's mother talking
about the fact that he didn't she didn't
know what he was doing doing history
perhaps because he wanted to be a pilot
and perhaps it was the wanted to fly
Spitfires it's those small little
details that just really remind you of
what is gone it's tragic on every level
yeah Mark two youngsters uh clearly
loving life and a school caretaker who
was described today as selfless
yes two people at the very start of
their lives and our adventures in the
world and uh one gentleman who so many
tributes from the community that he was
part of as to how much he had dedicated
his life to helping people I'm going to
say I'm in awe of families who at this
moment of dreadful trauma can have the
bravery and strength to speak out uh
publicly in the way they did I go forbid
I you know I I down that I would have
the strength to be able to do that in
their circumstances I do hope that we
don't come to expect this as being a
kind of
thing which should should automatically
be expected people these evidently are
families who've made incredibly Brave
decision that have taken this moment to
give a gift of their advice and their
message to that Community which I think
is hugely applicable yeah it really is
um and let's finish with the front of
the daily telegraphs uh more a fabulous
picture there of Glenda Jackson Oscar
and the actress of course former labor
MP
um and it's been really interesting
hearing today about her life and really
being reminded of of of two fantastic
careers
yeah God wasn't she a Powerhouse she won
two Academy Awards didn't one didn't
bother going and picking up either of
them they ended up as bookends in her
mother's house she said and she's had 23
years as a labor MP after she'd won an
Oscar Tony Emmy and she was one of the
most articulate performers that we had
in the House of Commons and it really
shows in the tributes you have papers
like the Telegraph and the Daily Mail
who would you know you think normally
would be opposed to someone like Glenda
Jackson who was a committed socialist
but no they are staying there and
they're paying tribute I think that
shows the absolute command and Legacy
that she has and the respect that she
garnered for her long and illustrious
career fighting for people's rights yeah
and Mark when we hear about uh MP's egos
as we do quite a lot she is one who
appeared not to have an ego she didn't
even bother going to pick up her two
Oscars
and dare I say you even hear the actors
often have egos as well but so so she
managed the double whammy of defining
expectations on on that front but it's
also it's also as a reminder about how
important it is that we have people from
which are people in in Parliament both
house of parliament from a really wide
range of perspectives and expertise ins
you know it's totally valid for there to
be young MPS um as well as MPS who who
are late in their lives I'm not someone
who signs up so you must have done a
certain number of Decades of something
else but it's great to have Parliament
leavened and improved by such a range of
of different backgrounds and hers was
one of the most unique and she was a
star of more commonwise which we
shouldn't forget no and we've been great
watching that clip again today hasn't it
uh Mark Moya thank you very much
malcolmoy will be staying with us for
the next hour to discuss tonight's news
and tomorrow's headlines right now let's
take a look at the weather